President Trump goes to Capitol Hill
today to press house Republicans on a
pair of immigration bills while the
uproar gets louder over his zero
tolerance policy for illegal immigrants
67% of Americans in a CBS News poll say
separating children from parents on the
southern border is unacceptable
17 percent say it's acceptable our poll
also finds 62 percent of Americans
disapprove of the president's handling
of immigration 35 percent approved Paula
Reid is at the White House Paula good
morning good morning when the president
meets with House Republican leaders
tonight he will demand funding for a
border wall border security and an end
to catch and release but given the sharp
divisions within the Republican Party
over this issue it's unclear whether any
bill that's been proposed could actually
pass we're doing the right thing we're
taking care of these children
last night Attorney General Jeff
Sessions defended the administration's
zero-tolerance policy which he first
announced in April hopefully people will
get the message and come through the
border at the port of entry and not
break break across the border unlawfully
newly released Department of Homeland
Security numbers show 2342 children were
separated from their parents at the
border from May 5th to do 9th I say it's
very strongly the Democrats fault their
obstruction they're really
obstructionist and they are obstructing
President Trump said Democrats should
back a broad immigration bill if they
want to end the practice of separating
children from their parents who come
here illegally the United States will
not be a migrant camp you take a look at
the death and destruction that's been
caused by people coming into this
country without going through a process
and they could be murderers and thieves
and so much else the president is saying
that this is all on the Democrats but
it's their law that's just not right
that's not true
outrage from lawmakers on both sides
continues to grow all of us who are
saying these images of children being
pulled away from from moms
dad's and tears were horrifying this has
to stop it's so challenges the
conscience of our country that it must
be changed must be changed immediately
the children are not being used as a
pond a defiant homeland security
secretary Kirsten Nielsen defended the
practice we are trying to protect the
children which is why I'm asking
Congress to act
senator Camilla Harris joined several of
her Democratic colleagues in calling on
Nielson to resign she has I think
evidenced again an inability to run that
agency Republican senator Ted Cruz says
he will introduce emergency legislation
that would provide temporary shelters so
that families could be detained together
now some Republicans are worried that
all of this could drag down the entire
party during a critical election year
but other Republicans tell me they are
actually giving voters exactly what they
voted for which is strict enforcement of
our immigration laws
Alex Paula thank you